[Music]
may review the lore so far what we have
gathered so far Johnny he's a compulsive
liar he ones sugar but most importantly
he's a hero
he puts up with online abuse domestic
abuse and he's only two years old that's
crazy
moving on the family we have
refrigerator now we don't know a lot
about refrigerator we don't know how he
became part of the family but he's what
lifts Johnny's up
he's one makes Johnny pulled through all
the abuse we also have Chia a very
important character try not to stare at
chia for too long he or she will consume
your soul you have been advised but
perhaps most important of all the leader
the mastermind behind it all yes I'm
talking about papa that's right we don't
say daddy anymore we say yes Papa if you
see daddy
you best be running especially if you're
carrying sugar or any sweet items or
perhaps toothpaste run run like the wind
because Papa's gonna get you now what
are you talking about oh I'm talking
about this video bye billion surprise
toys which apparently has 134 million
yeah okay it's pretty decent I suppose
if you haven't watched the video don't
worry I will sing it for you it goes
Johnny Johnny yes papa
yes Papa eating sugar eating sugar no
papa telling lies telling lies no papa
open wide open wide hahaha 134 million
views everybody what does it take to
become big on YouTube just make this
just create this now we're trying to
understand why this video got
why does Papa want Johnny so badly we
don't know we're still figuring out all
the details
Johnny Johnny yes Papa eating sugar no
papa telling lies no papa open wine
damn damn that's an open wide mouth
incredible so we have refrigerator
stores things inside of him why is the
same tan he's not a fan mommy don't care
Johnny self innocent manipulative
omnipotent I don't trust him either okay
- yeah I don't care
we have ice cream we're planting sleeps
with Johnny there's so much more
involved in this family there's so many
different dots that are connected but
they all Rachel lead back to Papa the
entire family could starve to death at
any moment because Popeye isn't letting
to me apparently
Johnny is confirmed for smash that's
epic but there's something about Johnny
as well
that makes me a bit uncomfortable I
don't like him I'm gonna be honest I
don't like Johnny Johnny oh hi mark
hitting Lisa hitting Lisa I did not
telling lies telling lies [ __ ] mark
open mouth open mouth ha ha ha ha Johnny
Johnny yes papa it's been 10 years
already you have to let me go the crash
wasn't your fault
Johnny very good we have the Johnny
no okay let it be known if there's one
thing you know about this mean I did not
chill this mean I have nothing to do
with this meme getting popular and I'm
here to kill it all I've discovered this
meme dark secret
everyone is perplexed why this meme is
popular who made this mean there's a ton
of mystery I will reveal it but first of
all I must reveal II do killing I'm here
to save the universe gap damn it
first of all I mean second of all are we
just gonna sit here and pretend like
toys in Japan watch toys in Japan okay
are we all the sudden pretending that
this never got a 60 million views okay
so don't hang me about Johnny Johnny
being weird with this is the kids watch
the box of course voxcom of course
another enemy made a mean review all
this mean hmm hmm suspicious yes I know
but the message they they point out is
that in the essence it seems to be a
rare mean that appeals to every kind of
me maker and every kind of audience not
me box I hate this mean you have no
taste you have no integrity
if you shell this me okay
and number three okay this meme is
getting DMCA takedown left and right
whoever it is creating these videos it's
deleting anyone that is trying to meme
it whether it's some Twitter dailymotion
or you
- if you upload with Johnny Johnny your
video will get deleted so the tweet
announcing my last video was taken down
by the guys from made the Johnny Johnny
video the following material has been
removed new video Johnny Johnny yes papa
sir onyx video got removed great hey
remember when there was a mean that we
have to vote for the you to not
copyright law around me so that you
couldn't just delete means oh that's
right we are already living it laws
don't matter because YouTube and Twitter
they don't care
Oh someone sent a DMCA well we better
remove the video it
I even debated whether I should not
review this me because I know we will
just get a DMCA takedown and the thing
is the most annoying thing about this
whole thing is it's not even original
content you're making a nursery rhyme
you don't own the nursery right it is a
public domain but YouTube is like oh
okay
sorry papa sorry papa yeah yeah go ahead
and give a CA this video show me my
scene gomennasai for five what the real
enemy of this me means is Indians okay
this video is clearly made by Indians
now this is not racism let it be clear
this is another evidence of the Indians
taking over YouTube first off we had
t-series they're taken over my channel
in subscriber count everyone's like well
I never heard of t-series oh you have it
haven't you
that's right the Indians are sneaking in
on us and now they're doing it again
with this channel being created
obviously by Indians and they're
attacking us through our memes first
they take our means
and they take our freedom and I'm not
just gonna sit here it responsibly like
Fox News pretending like everyone loves
who's mean when it's clearly telling not
just me but the Internet is well along
with it we need to kill papa Pathan
needs to die that's why I'm giving this
meme a zero bye papa
bye papa next Reem that's the thing
about annoys him even more about this
super meme is that everyone has been so
preoccupied with the yes Papa mean
they've been brainwashed then I wasn't
been posing any other DS and means we
have that let me guess you're a ho it
was and it was beautiful
it's a sad man this is sad let me guess
your home it was and it was beautiful
hey what's next minecraft perhaps let me
get your hope it was any bush boom
another marble meme how long has it been
they just keep coming they just keep
coming
no to be fair our large fab did a
green-screen on it so if you want to
mean this the floodgates are open enjoy
everyone
you brought you face to face with the
master of the mystic arts where do you
think he brought you let me guess your
home
it was it was beautiful hey it's my trap
everybody but what uh hmm my favorite
one is the one large shredded let me
guess it's like when all this time
greens turning out this and you can put
anything so what do you put Peter
Griffin that I would love to live inside
that man I'm giving this me McCoy okay
just because I'm desperate to get any
other meme out there at this point
last but not least ben shapiro the
destroyer of worlds at well Stein Daniel
I can really only think of one way to
answer this and it's in musical form so
I think we're gonna have to do that okay
okay okay you may or may not have seen
these videos pop up in your recommended
feed going ben shapiro destroys every
college snowflake dilutional leftist
confronts ben shapiro ben shapiro
crushes ketchup arrow annihilates ben
shapiro destroys for my favorite video
ben shapiro these are all great by the
way is ben shapiro destroys my sand
castle that i spent all day making you
just got trolled lib [ __ ]
you can't build same castle they're not
real your dumb ball ben shapiro
demolicious woman in line at Walgreens
for saying tuesday is basically monday
two women am i right brofist the screen
right now if you agree Ben Shapiro
reaches such heights of logic he
instantaneously a cheese
yes and recap okay I can't even say it I
don't even want to say it ironically the
me miss is soda okay this is video going
to be ten minutes I don't know
I still see bananas in my room can't
take back the love that I gave you it's
to the point where I love and I hate you
okay so basically I am monkey it's this
video ten minutes this were really bad
memes since we assuming mice and
everybody like for Eminem ignore for
Logan Paul that's it for now I see you
guys next time